okay on today's episode of um garage
mechanic I bought us a key Honda Pilot
to use as a spare key for my
my Honda Pilot I just just got into
actual I want to try and program it and
see if it works
let's go
um this is
okay the next step is plugging in uh the
diagnostic tool so the car right here
I'm gonna plug it in right here
okay it's plugged in now then I'll turn
the car ignition on but I'm gonna start
the car
okay
the ignition is on but I didn't start
the car so I go to
um
service
then IMO keys
and or choose the car which is Honda
then
um I choose automatic selection for the
to to read the VIN
okay
read VIN
then it will take
some few seconds to read okay then you
read and you say okay
um this guy is made in USA I'll just
clicked USA
then it will ask if it's uh 2018 on a
pilot which is correct
yes
so it's the system
then alt function
push to start
key access control unit
registration
[Music]
keyless access remote
add a new access key it will give you
description of
click ok
then another okay
say turn the ignition off
turn it off
and it says wait ECU good for DCU to
stabilize
then you say one original
all yakis must be in a vehicle yes which
is correct
I have
the original key right
click ok
say turn the English on on
which I did now
is establishing communication
take all
original access remote out of the
vehicle
and press ok
the original key is out right now this
is original kick out
go back
and I press
okay
let's say only take one new
remote access to the vehicle and press
ok
this is
right here
so I take it in
let me press ok
establishing communication
says
the keyless access remote is registered
correctly so press ok
turn the ignition off
[Music]
using the knob of Link should turn the
ignition back on okay
okay it's back on
[Music]
the registration access screen remote
has been completed
okay
turn the ignition off
turn the ignition on
[Music]
okay
okay let me try the new key
first of all let me even let me try to
lock the car
oh it works okay let me try and start it
from outside and see if it movement of
Truth
strike
so where
six words